[Musique]
étranger
non je ne connais pas cet homme non je suis fort
euh je suis fort
j'ai les pires
capacités de reconnaissance faciale au monde en fait euh
youri gagarine yuri gagar n'est-ce pas oui
c'est youri gagarine  bien sûr
autour de l'espace mais Jésus revient
en jugement le jour du jugement
arrive
juste euh
avec
[Musique]
oh
alfredo
[Musique]
étranger
mundo
[Musique]
je pense que c'est le gars russe
le  premier gars dans l'espace
yuri quelque chose de bien
jury très gaggart je ne me souviens pas de son
nom de famille euh
mais je pense qu'il était l'un des astronautes russes
n'est-il pas comme un acteur avec lequel il était dans ce
film avec comme euh
chevy chase et dan aykroyd comme  de retour dans
les années 80
miracle
liberté
spoutnik c'est l'univers c'est
tout c'est de quoi tout est fait